Let us return to means-ends analysis for just another minute.
Just to see how means-ends analysis, might try to work with this problem, and
get into difficulties. So this is the goal state, painted ladder and
painted ceiling. And this is the initial state. Now means-ends analysis may
enumerate the operators that have to deal with the painted ladder and
the painted ceiling. Here the operator might be paint ladder.
Here the operator might be paint ceiling, but that requires some
pre-condition climb up ladder which is not satisfy the initial state.
So maintenance analysis picked the goal painted ladder. And select
the operator paint ladder, which gets the maintenance owner to this state.
This is the holistic method. Here is the paint-ladder specified at the right,
and you can see the peak conditions of paint-ladder, match the initial state,
and the post conditions match the successive state. Now that means since
analysis has achieved the first goal of painted ladder it make turn to
the second goal of painted ceiling. Recall that this is the current state. So,
mean sense analysis may pick the operator climb-ladder, as a peak condition for
the operator of painted ceiling. But note what happens,
when precondition of climb ladder, constitutes a postcondition of paint ladder.
So this is not dry ladder, this is quest dry ladder. There is a conflict here.
In a situation like this now, the robot, would need to just wait for
the ladder to become dry again, before climb ladder is a [UNKNOWN]. So
it seems as, as if the people who are sometimes hired for working on a home or
using main sense analysis. The first being the ladder, then the goal weight,
until the ladder dries up, and then they of course expect me to pay them for
their time. To summarize, we have a plan for achieving one of the goals,
Painted Ladder. But this particular plan clobbers achieving the other goal,
Painted(Ceiling), because it creates a condition, that makes it impossible to
achieve the other goal. The question now becomes [UNKNOWN] reason about
the conflict between these codes? How can planning systematically find out,
how to organize these various operators, so that these conflicts do not occur?
What we have described here, this goal clobbering, is true for
all simple planners, sometimes called linear planners. Linear planner,
does not try to reason about the conflict between these goals. Does not try to
reason about how the plan for one goal may clobber another goal. Instead it
just goes about making plans as if those goals can be achieved in any order.